gib gefragt hättest du auch mal binnen
24 stunden live stream
alle meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer folge minecraft
heiden wo ich einen zig spiele und ihr
wisst dass freunde ihr habt
wahrscheinlich schon im titel gelesen
aber wenn ich mein kreft heiden zig
spiele dann heißt das dass ich auch
fragen beantworte ich habe wieder bei
twitter gesagt er und dann hashtag fragt
luca könnt ihr wenn ihr bock hab ein
paar fragen war für mich stellen
da kamen diesmal echt richtig coole
fragen also sonst denke ich mir jede
fünfte frage nehme ich mal irgendwie mal
dran weil die noch nicht beantwortet
wurde und weil die auch cool ist oder
irgendwie so aber diesmal kann echt
richtig viele coole fragen an sich
nehmen einfach mal so ein quatsch blog
hier wieder und ich habe mir auch
diesmal anstatt sonst immer so neun bis
zehn fragen habe ich mir diesmal glaube
ich 15 fragen sogar ausgesucht weil ich
mir gedacht habe er ja eigentlich kein
paar mehr fragen eingehen damit du nicht
immer so lange über eine frage rede
sondern ein bisschen mehr beantwortet
deswegen fangen direkt mit frage nummer
eins von mlp hashtag frack luca fehlt
die zeit welche do you tube investierst
das würde ich so nicht als fehler
bezeichnen aber es ist halt schon so
dass ich täglich 23 stunden minimum muss
sich in youtube stärken um so ein video
fertig zu kriegen weil ich das hier
jetzt auch bearbeitet und so weiter und
so fort also ich bin ja jetzt nicht so
dass das aufnehmen
mit irgendwie ne app oder so und dann
das direkt hochladen sondern das beste
beispiel sind wirklich diese iphone-apps
da muss man erst mal richtig viel
vorbereiten app suchen danach das ganze
land hat aufnehmen und vor allem das
schneiden dauert extrem langen dass dort
bei merck immer eine stunde und deswegen
ich würde mich sagen die zeit fehlt mir
aber es ist halt einfach so ein hobby
von mir und wenn ich aufhören möchten
würde tun lassen für dich das tun aber
da ich nicht möchte mache ich weiter und
für sein hobby investiert man gerne zeit
aber ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass mir
die zeit zu grundsätzlich fehlt ist ein
23 frage steckt fragt luca ist im moment
ein was im moment ein lieblingslied erst
seine videos sind hammer erst mal danke
für das lob und mein lieblingslied der
zeit habe ich gar nicht ich hatte noch
nie so ein richtiges lieblingslied also
ich habe nie gesagt ja das ist mein
lieblingslied dann ich war relativ viel
immer so aber derzeit höre ich extrem
viel wird der ist solid geworden hier
also wie kann er denn hier solltet
werden das geht doch gar nicht
mein lieblingslied
de es ist schwer definierbar ich zurzeit
echt extrem viel sachen höhere die denke
ich keiner von euch kennt und zwar ganz
ganz alten jazz von charles mingus höre
ich sehr sehr gerne mag der kann mich ja
durch das gitter trotz höherer extrem
viel late night jazz von charles mingus
unter anderem von anderen jazz künstlern
damals aber auch wenn ich mal feiern
gehe oder so dann dann auch electro
dance music was in die richtung
elektronisch aber sonst jetzt derzeit
einfach habe ich richtig gern zu abende
wo ich mir einfach plattenspieler an
machen und einfach ganz viel jazz höre
aber ich habe jetzt keinen lied wo ich
wirklich sagen dass ich das am liebsten
höre außer goodbye pork pie hat das
könnt ihr so einfach mal bei youtube
eingehen ich hab keine angst für popper
verfolgt werde
goodbye pork pie hält das finde ich ganz
geil das nicht ich möchte mich hier
erhalten aber so ein richtiges
lieblingslied habe ich nicht carina
fragt wärst du die blind oder taub die
frage habe ich einen weißen extrem
kreative frage ist eine ganz ganz
interessante frage
ich werde mich jetzt einfach mal hin
stellen eben damit die frage gut
beantworten kann und zwar blind oder
taub sind zwei nein nein nein nein
als er diese nicht wirklich ein kind
oder taub ist eine sache ich würde auf
jeden fall wenn ich tot bin kann ich ja
keine musik hören und ich liebe gute
musik allerdings wenn ich blind wäre
könnte ich einfach gar nichts mehr sehen
das heißt ich denke ich würde mich dafür
entscheiden dass ich lieber nichts hören
könnte als dass ich die welt nicht mehr
sehen kann weil ich denke somit mit den
augen und so die welt wahrnehmen die
schönheit der welt darauf könnte ich
glaube ich nicht verzichten also ich
werde dann lieber tauscht games hast du
mal vorrichtung pv peking zu werden
beziehungsweise zu trainieren
nein rangers trikot [ __ ] [ __ ] denke man
sieht gerade schon ich spiele halten
zieht so dass ich einfach vor den leuten
rumlaufe und weg lauf und alles mögliche
hallo na wer hätte ich lieber nicht
geschlagen ich ich hätte ich ihn nicht
geschlagen dann will ich einfach in den
raum gekommen
aber ich denke ihr merkt das auch schon
selber ich möchte eigentlich gar nicht
gut werden also formate wie bei mir wie
minecraft triple was übrigens auch schon
lange nicht mehr kamen
das sind sachen wie ich finde da ist es
gerade interessant dass ich da nicht gut
bin im pvp weil ich fände es gibt so
viele leute die gut sind die youtube
videos machen und ich weiß nicht also
ich bin damit eigentlich ganz zufrieden
dass ich nicht ganz so gut bin weil dann
habe ich so mehr freiraum das ganze zu
bearbeiten witzig zu bearbeiten weil
wenn ich darin mega gut wenn man
natürlich von montes machen wie ich alle
töten find' ich finds selber witziger
ich schaue auch übels gern conan o'brien
vielleicht kennt ihr kluges gamer von
conan o'brien
ich schaue ich mir gerne weil er einfach
so schlecht dass er läuft den call of
duty braucht 40 versuchen über eine
straße zu laufen entdeckt danach die
brücke und alles da lach ich mir weg
weil wenn er einfach überlaufen wird und
jeden töten würde wenn ich selbst nicht
interessant und ich möchte videos machen
die mir selbst gefallen deswegen ich
will nicht sagen dass ich absichtlich
schlecht bin ich bin einfach schlecht
aber ich möchte mich ich habe jetzt
keinen großen kein großes interesse
daran
deshalb wäre eine pvp zelda fragt er
steckt luca gehst du gerne feiern also
übrigens wenn ihr fragen habt letztes
mal waren mega viele hier in den
kommentaren
ihr müsstet mir dafür auf twitter folgen
bzw nicht folgen sondern einfach nur
unter den hashtag fragt luca einfach da
die fragen stellen wie bei twitter kann
ich das viel besser durch ge mit dem
handy als wenn ich da bei youtube das
ganze anschauen
ja ich gehe recht gerne feiern aber es
kommt immer so auf meine meinung meinen
also auf meine stimmung gut also nicht
nicht mtm rudi ich hab das jetzt auf
englisch gesagt welche irgendwie mir mut
gerade ein bisschen mehr in den kopf kam
dass es komisch dass man fremdwort
schneller in den kopf kommt als antwort
meiner mutter schritt hatte er also um
auf die frage zurückzukommen ich gehe
eigentlich schon recht gern feiern aber
es kommt dann wirklich mal auf die
stimmung an also zum beispiel gestern
abend war ich einfach halt hier zu hause
an einem samstag bei wir freitag schon
los waren da waren wir überall in köln
und im youtube haus und dort fertig
alles und wanda halt ein bisschen
unterwegs und waren alle auch erst um
vier uhr im bett oder so deswegen ich
gehe schon gern feiern aber zum beispiel
heute oder gestern hätte ich auch nicht
verein gehen können weil ich einfach
mega fertig war von dem tag davor noch
und eigentlich schon aber es kommt immer
auf den tag an und auch was das fan
event ist weil ich mag zum beispiel
black musik überhaupt nicht ich kann mir
das mal an wenn ich im auto sitze oder
autofahrer oder so aber zum feiern kann
ich black musik überhaupt nicht
ausstehen
deswegen ist es halt so es kommt immer
auf die circumstances um die auf die
umstände an jetzt kommt mir circumstance
auch schon eher im kopf als umständen
sophie frage at contra versteckt
freiburger würdest du gerne mal für ein
jahr in ein anderes land und wenn ja
welches ein jahr finde ich ein bisschen
lang aber ich habe bald sechsmonatiges
auslandspraktikum
da werden dann wahrscheinlich keine
videos kommen oder ich werd blogs machen
oder irgendwie so wenn jeder ideen habt
was ich da eigentlich machen könnte weil
ich weiß nicht ob ich wirklich meinen pc
und alles mitnehmen wenn ich meinen
auslandspraktikum mache wenn ihr da
irgendwelche ideen habt würde ich mich
schon freuen wenn die kulinarischen
könnte aber es ist so dass ich sechs
monate auslandspraktikum habe
und da ist es halt so dass ich mach das
wahrscheinlich so dass sich drei monate
ins ausland gehen und drei monate hier
in deutschland ein praktikum machen und
im ausland werde ich dann halt drei
monate sein und da werde ich mal schauen
wie mir das gefällt mal länger als zwei
wochen zwei wochen war bisher mein
längstes im ausland werde ich mal
schauen wie es ist länger als zwei
wochen irgendwo in einem anderen land zu
sein ich denke es wird ganz cool sein
auch mal neue leute kennenzulernen neue
sachen zu erleben und alles ich denke es
wird richtig cool aber für ein jahr war
halt schon lange ich mache jetzt erstmal
diese drei monate damals praktikum
arbeite dann nebenbei an vor allem
dieses ein jahr kann ich gar nicht
umsetzen weil ich jetzt erstmal drei
jahre studiere und das hätte ich ja
quasi direkt nach dem abi machen können
aber so wer bin ich nicht abgeneigt
davon also ich war auch kurz davor
sondern auslandsjahr zu machen was mir
auch angesehen wird dass es da nicht
eine klasse wiederholen muss war ich
kurz davor kann ich auch jedem nur
empfehlen weil ich davon auch nur gutes
bisher gehört habe aber derzeit kann ich
mir das nicht vorstellen weil ich halt
derzeit mit ganz vielen anderen sachen
beschäftigt das gefragt wirst wie chat
oder markt zusammenziehen
das ist in dem mit mega schwierige frage
aber ich denke mit max weil ich mag halt
einfach schon so seit 20 jahren
denn die stehen peter und schatz ist als
wir in köln bei der tante von max
geplant haben war justin mir das
ladekabel geklaut er hat mir die
bettdecke erst geklaut ja ja die frage
zu beantworten ich denke aber ich komme
also ich denke mit max aber das kann
sich natürlich alles noch verändern bin
ich jetzt in der kasse ja tatsache ich
bin den scheiß verkäufer kommt fühlte
mich auch nicht ganze stadt lucca lieber
für immer softdrink oder wasser ich bin
jemand ich liebe wasser und ich hasse
softdrinks auch als wir in köln haben
wir uns halt so getränke gekauft und so
abends weil wir an und hat noch
losfahren und so ich glaube den simon
hat man es im blog gesehen dass wir am
bahnhof an und so jeder kauft sie zum
mountain view oder eine kuh oder
irgendwie sowas
ich könnte mir einfach 15 liter volvic
dich so mitnehmen wir da hin
also ich weiß nicht ich mag wasser und
ich habe auch hier meiner wohnung nur
wasser und halten ein paar bierchen
irgendwie wenn man kumpel vorbei kommt
oder so das training jetzt hat mich in
meiner freizeit und sohn meiner freizeit
könnte ich mir nie vorstellen dass ich
jetzt irgendwo hingehe mir eine fanta
oder irgendwie so also ich weiß nicht
ich finde was ich gut und
softdrinks ist halt einfach nur zucker
und ich weiß nicht ob ihr dieses video
kennt wo cola einfach mal destilliert
wurde oder so ich weiß nicht genau wie
man das in chemie kalisch richtigen
deutsch ausdrückt jedenfalls war es da
so dass da einfach nur zucker zu sehen
war danach als es so verbrannt wurde
deswegen bin ich da überhaupt nicht
erkennen von und werde einfach bei
wasser bleiben beziehe mich für was
entscheide gefragt hättest du auch mal
bock auf 100 24 stunden live stream
da muss ich sagen 24 stunden also ich
war ja bei kalle und und rewe kurz zu
gast und das war zwar cool und so dass
man da direkt mit euch mit der community
interagieren kann
aber was mir halt bei den beiden halt
aufgefallen ist als ich dann irgendwann
so sein zimmer zurückgezogen hat man ja
auch gesehen und levi war halt immer
noch total aufgedreht und alles also für
mich war das überhaupt nichts das wäre
mir viel zu stressig wenn schon mal
alleine einfach so aber nicht das so
ganz viele leute bei mir um touren im
zimmer und alles das wäre mir viel zu
stressig aber von 24 stunden
wie man sicherlich nichts gegen nur
derzeit lässt es sich komplett überhaupt
nicht vereinbaren mit meinem studienplan
mit meinen sachen die ich geplant habe
also jetzt auf mein leben bezogen sich
auf youtube bezogen lässt es sich halt
derzeit überhaupt nicht vereinbaren
damit weil ich auch der zeit gerade in
der klausurphase bin ich habe zum
beispiel am donnerstag eine klausur
die ich schreiben muss habe ich danach
noch eine woche danach eine klausur da
muss ich mir eine studienarbeit fertig
machen ein paar sachen wo es einfach
derzeit nicht reinpasst 24 stunden mich
überhaupt nur mit youtube zu
beschäftigen oder mit twittern oder wie
auch immer jedenfalls irgendwann
eventuell ja aber da braucht es denke
ich noch ein bisschen zeit hier fragt
hallo war hier früher hattest du ja mal
gesagt dass youtube nach deiner uni zeit
für dich vorbei sein wie denkst du das
jetzt immer noch so
ich hab das ja mal gesagt dass ich mir
als erst mal so als ziel gesetzt hatte
kam halt damals die frage auf jahren
möchte ich lieber aufhören
jeder sagt sie ja eigentlich so lange es
mir spaß macht und so das habe ich halt
auch gesagt habe ich gesagt okay
nach meinem studium ist es halt so weit
ich denke sie studiert hat erstmal noch
3d zweieinhalb jahre und danach mache
ich wahrscheinlich noch meinen master
das heißt ich schwöre noch viereinhalb
jahre das heißt mindestens oder
mindestens mindestens 200 jahre müssten
jedoch müsst ihr mich noch aushalten
nicht ich hab das hat damals gesagt weil
ich weiß nicht wie es ist ob ich das mit
studium ist schon schwer aber studien
ist hat wenigstens noch ein bisschen
flexibel aber wenn ich dann in einem
beruf bin wo ich wirklich dauerhaft im
büro da sein muss dann frage ich mich
halt wie das ist ob ich da youtube noch
unterbringen kann weil ich mich dann
halt wahrscheinlich auch außerhalb des
berufs mit dem beruf beschäftigen muss
deswegen ich werde youtube auf keinen
fall aufhören weil ich keine lust mehr
daran habe sondern menschen weil ich
keine zeit mehr daran finde weil die
lust ich weiß nicht also wenn man eine
hobby ich hab das jetzt schon seit zwei
drei jahren wenn man das so lange hat
dann hat man doch eigentlich sein ganzes
leben lang mehr oder weniger bock drauf
so wie wenn man mit sechs jahren fußball
anfängt ist es nicht so dass man mit mit
18 sagte ich interessiere mich gar nicht
mehr dafür man entwickelt immer noch ein
bisschen interesse oder fernweh danach
deswegen ich bin da auf jeden fall
jemand der sagt ich hör auf damit wenn
ich keine zeit mehr dafür finden habe
ich denke oder wenn ich keinen spaß mehr
dran aber ich denke dass ich daran immer
spaß haben sein tun werden wir machen
jetzt noch zwei fragen bevor das video
zu ende ist und zwar schreibt die my
lord hashtag luca likes of fine arts auf
instagram dabei vernazza instagram ist
halt die sache dass ich nicht weiß wo
ich die finden soll also
ich liebe ja das heißt hier total
komisch an aber ich gehe dann immer auf
profile von defender zu machen und haben
ihn wieder an einem sonntag und dann ist
halt auch informiert dann lag ich das
mal aber sonst wenn da leute dann mir
und in die kommentare bei youtube
schreiben ja ich habe natürlich bei
instagram gemacht und so vor drei wochen
schon los das immer ignoriert dann denkt
wir sind nie dann hab ich nicht gesehen
weil eigentlich so wenn wenn leute
bilder von mir hoch laden die ich hoch
geladen habt dann dann finde ich das
halt um kreativ ist zwar cool und so
dass wir dann so bilder von mir hören
lade wenn euch die gefallen oder so
natürlich habe ich ja nichts gegen aber
das ist halt so einfach so ein bild
hochgeladen aber sollen ferner
beantworten natürlich schon extrem viel
arbeit also wenn es gezeichnet ist und
soll deswegen ich mag das extrem gerne
wenn so etwas gemacht wird wenn etwas
gut gemacht wird und das dann auch gerne
oder oder macht davon einen screenshot
und latz bei mir selber hoch aber bisher
habe ich die halt immer recht schwer
gefunden aber java entwickelt und die
letzte frage von emily hashtag fragt
lukas schaust du selber noch youtube in
deiner freizeit
das ist ganz interessante frage und zwar
derzeit ist es wirklich so dass ich halt
ich hab halt netflix und ich bin jetzt
auf die serie is you zugestoßen und da
bin ich jetzt schon mit der ersten
staffel durch und es ist bei mir so dass
mittlerweile serien immer mehr youtube
ablösen youtube ist halt immer so ja
kann ich mir halt dauerhaft angucken
aber genau so ist es halt mit netflix
auch netflix ist quasi youtube nun
professionell du hast eine komplette
auswahl kannst dir aussuchen was sie
gucken will man muss gucken willst kann
stoppen und das irgendwann weiter
schauen uns und nicht so wie es
fernsehen
aber deswegen bin ich zur zeit eher so
der serien typ aber ich denke dass mit
youtube kommt irgendwann wieder und wenn
ich youtube schauen dann auf jeden fall
keine deutschen youtube schaue gar
keinen deutschen youtuber eigentlich
regelmäßig wo ich sage auch er hat ein
neues video solchen an sondern halt
wirklich nur englische und amerikanische
weil ich finde der humor weil sie nicht
ich finde halt einfach cooler und ich
mag die sprache und alles deswegen aber
derzeit bin ich echt mehr so der
serientäter freunde und damit will ich
sagen was auch schon wieder für diese
runde hashtag fragt luca wenn ihr eine
frage an ich hab folgt mir bei
twitter.com schrägstrich contractor und
zeigt es mit einer bewertung ob die
allgemein mehr von diesen videos hier
wollte weil ich sehe dass die gut
ankommen wenn dich fragen beantworten
spitzen
ddp